that was so cool it like at first I was
like are they we mean like they're
singing and then I clicked on it and it
was so it must have taken so much time
to do that to like peas all the little
things together but it was it was cool I
loved it
the cool ways being your song in a
different way yeah no definitely and I
loved all those characters they're all
Chris I mean singing our song some
traits as a fellow Canadian of you know
with collaborations dead melts you talk
about Calvin Harris maybe having too
many collaborations listen you think
about that do you choose how many you do
and do you think that the thing I am
personally really selective the collabs
that I do just because I don't want to
just get on a song just for hype or just
for whatever reason I if I really
believe in the song and if I can
contribute my own creativity or if I can
write on it and I always do and it's
always it's just about how you feel and
it's you're really into the song then
you should do it if not then obviously
don't but yeah just me personally I'm
just more selective with what the stuff
that I do because I want to give my all
you know but I think someone like Calvin
Harris he's a DJ like they're supposed
to do collabs right so I love all the
stuff that he's been doing it's so cool
like all is like the song that you just
didn't Khalid in future so good so keep
doing them keep bringing the new stuff
Calvin all the collapse I'm always down
it's a cool song I mean
one last being a logic the song that you
released with him so important with this
made being mental health what did that
mean to you to taking part in that
collaboration that really meant a lot I
mean you know going back to what I said
being really selective with the stuff
that I do and really wanting to give
everything in the song that song was
definitely one that I really wanted to
be on and logic he was so nice he called
me and he said he thought of me for the
song and um it really means a lot to me
that song just for so many reasons it's
so close to home and I think it's really
needed right now with everything that's
going on and the internet and flabber
bullying and so many people just feel
like they're not good enough and it's
important to show them that life is
worth living in it they need to they
need to be here you know it's important
so yeah